We've mentioned a little bit about relevancy already.
I think you've seen some cursor terms coming up a couple of times.
Again, this might be a term or something like this term might exist in other engines,
but I believe we're getting more into the domain now of terminology that might be unique to Unreal.
So you might not be familiar with this exact term, but you probably tackled something like it.
Relevancy is essentially the umbrella term used to describe how
and when data is sent to clients.
There are essentially rules that we can define whether or not certain data even should make its way to a particular client.
For example, if we're in a game like Player Unknown Battlegrounds or any of these kind of large,
I suppose to be kind of more on brand, I should be saying Fortnite.
If we're in a huge world and one client fires a bullet on my 5k by 5k island,
if they're on two opposite sides of the island, does client A need to know about client B's bullet being fired?
If they're too far away for the sound ever to make their way to that client,
if they're too far away for that bullet ever to possibly hit them,
then it's a fair assumption that it would be irrelevant.
And therefore, that's where we can take relevancy into account.
And by doing that, by not having to ever replicate any information about that bullet from client B to client A,
then we can obviously reduce our kind of bandwidth consumption.
That's a big win.
And also, not just about bandwidth, but it's also about our CPU, right?
Our server then doesn't have to perform certain calculations.
It's not having to maintain that object on the other client.
If an object is relevant, but then spends a long time out of relevancy, it will be destroyed.
And that's following the same destruction logic that we saw in our second session
when we talked about actors getting destroyed.
So that means that when it enters relevancy or re-enters relevancy, it will have its begin play called.
And when it leaves relevancy, it will have its destroy called.
And therefore, in the context of a multiplayer game,
actors can have their technically the same conceptual actor could have its begin play and destroy
called multiple times due to entering and leaving relevancy.
As I said kind of before, a lot of these concepts are stitched in the actor.
Actor is our kind of primary in point for a lot of the way that we replicate information over the server.
So relevancy is primarily an actor level thing.
If we have components on an actor, they don't really have a concept of relevancy.
Those components are automatically relevant if the actor that they are attached to is relevant.
And the same thing is going to be true for a lot of this functionality.
So when we talk about managing relevancy and how we actually do that,
the default implementation, so the primary way that Unreal assumes you would do relevancy is going to be distance.
Simply put, if something is too far away, do we care about it?
So with the example we gave as a bullet being fired, right, that's a kind of easy example.
If you're too far away to ever hear this, see it or get hit by it, then we can assume it's too far.
So by default, Unreal would consider one and a half kilometers to be too far away to be relevant.
But that is configurable on a, that particular distance functionality is configurable by a value.
It's called net cull distance squared.
So we can actually just quickly go and see that.
As we said, most of this stuff is done on actor.
If I go to net cull, you can see this is the value.
This is a squared distance, obviously for mathematical optimization sake.
So obviously this doesn't look anything like 1.5K, but if you take 1,500 centimeters and times it by 1,500 centimeters,
you would arrive at this value.
So just be aware that this is a squared value and therefore square root your value to get in centimeters,
how many, or unreal units, which essentially match the map to centimeters, how many units this is going to be.
And yeah, there's a couple of instances where we would actually want to entirely forgo this check.
And that's going to be very global actors that might be kind of game systems.
There's certain actors that would typically want to do this on things like the game state would be obvious examples where it's like,
at what point would the game state not always be relevant to you?
Like everyone should need to know the kind of global information about the game, right?
So the game state is going to be a typical example of something that is going to be always relevant.
And that means that we're not going to do any of these distance based relevancy checks or any kind of overrides that we can do.
It's just we're just going to say, oh, rather than doing relevancy checks,
this thing is always relevant and therefore not even going to check that.
Similarly, we can also, there's kind of additional filtering we can do.
We can say that this thing is always relevant to the person who owns it.
So that may, you know, it's regardless of how far away from it, it's a little bit like always relevant,
but it's only relevant to a particular client connection.
So this is only going to be relevant to a particular player controller or whatever.
And then in some circumstances, you know, maybe distance isn't what we need.
Maybe we've broken our game up into some kind of like partitioning logic.
Maybe we have, based off some kind of clever game logic,
we know that this thing is only going to be relevant when we're looking at it.
So, you know, distance is not going to be the metric that we want to use.
If we want to utilize that, we can actually override this distance based functionality with a function called isNetRelevantFor.
And what that essentially says is we kind of establish a relationship between actor A and actor B.
We say, is this actor A relevant for actor B?
And then we can do whatever functionality we kind of need to do there.
Yeah, for example, maybe an actor is only relevant to actors of the same team.
If we're on a red versus blue and we've got an actor that is, I don't know, our teams,
something that manages UI for notifying our teammates when our flag has been captured
or a flag has been picked up by an enemy team member.
Obviously, the enemy team doesn't actually need to know about that actor.
That might be a case that you want to override isNetRelevantFor,
and therefore it's not owned by a single one of those connections.
So we can't rely on only relevant to owner, but we can say,
oh, this team manager actor is always relevant for anyone who's on the same team.
And also whilst that's the primary example of when we would be relevant or irrelevant is based off distance,
there is also a kind of shortcut that Unreal would make that it's worth bearing in mind
that if an actor is hidden, which is an Unreal concept of being hidden,
and if an actor is hidden and has its collision turned off,
then it will also be kind of perceived as standard as irrelevant.
So just worth bearing that in mind if you're hiding your actors and turning their collision off
that your network will by default perceive that as irrelevant.